I actually um came here to
tell you that um as if a few months ago
um I'm now a Christian.
So, why is your name Abdurrahman?
I want to change I want to I'd like to
change it. Oh, good. All right. I don't
know. That's why your name's
Abdurrahman. So, I got trigger-happy.
So, all right. So, I'm glad you left
Islam. What happened? Let me see how I
can help you. What's going on? Yeah, so
uh you and God Logic and
I've been watching you guys for a couple
years now.
And I've been
I've been watching you guys uh for a
couple years and
um
>> [clears throat]
>> I um
I it it it really
it really to be honest with you, it was
a bunch of different uh things that cuz
initially when I first, you know,
learned who you were, I said um you
know, oh, I'm going to I'm going to bust
Sam. I think he's, you know, I want to
prove him wrong so bad. And so, I
started studying. I started uh listening
to the uh sheikhs and imams and trying
to get all the answers so I can just
have it all written down and so I can
just come on here and and and just, you
know, show you how you're wrong on
everything. But every single time I
tried,
it was okay, you know, it's the the most
improbable
compilation of uh
facts that like that that I had have to
like kind of stitch together
in order for it to make sense in Islam.
And it was always
always the case in every single topic.
And you know, you guys brought up the
Islamic dilemma.
You know, you guys brought you know, so
many things and it's like, okay, in
order to get those things answered, I
have to jump through so many hoops. So,
for me, it just it was just the most
unlikely compilation of improbable facts
that required mental gymnastics in order
to justify the claim for Islam.
So
So it was
What were you? Did you convert to Islam?
Yes. Yeah, I can tell
that you sound like Well, again, you
can't go by someone's voice, but it was
most likely you were a convert. So, what
were you before you became Muslim?
Well, pretty much agnostic. Agnostic.
So, your family from a Christian home?
No. No, from agnostic home. So, glory to
the Lord Jesus Christ. So, you saw that
the Christian side tried their best to
be as accurate and honest and fair with
the citations, right? Yes.
And you when you went fact-checked, we
didn't misquote anything, did we? No,
you guys were very honest. That's
actually what I That's what actually
appealed to me.
Yep. And yet when you go to the Muslims
and confront them, they came up with
explanations that were so silly,
right? That it was embarrassing, right?
>> Correct. Good. So, how long were you a
Muslim? Uh 17 years.
>> [screaming]
>> Wow, you wasted 17 years of your life. I
know. I know. That's all right. God is a
God of redemption. God is a God of
redemption. But in those 17 years, did
you end up marrying?
I'm so
No, I still not, actually. I almost did,
but I I I did not. Yeah, because that
would have been hard to then marry a
Muslim and have children. So, the Lord
Jesus saved you from that. All right, so
now
what how long ago did you leave Islam,
you said?
Um well, I left Islam maybe about a year
and some change ago, but I became
Christian a couple months ago. All
right. But I didn't officially I guess
you could say I didn't really leave
Islam officially, but in my mind, I left
Islam, but I didn't like officially
leave it until because I I started going
to this uh
Eastern Orthodox Church. Excellent. And
then [clears throat] they and then I was
they didn't like
they didn't make me a Christian right
away.
Oh yeah, yeah. You have to go through a
process and then they chrismate you and
baptize you. Yes. Yes, so I and I think
they'll do it on Easter, right?
I'm sorry, I didn't hear you. I think
They they Well, they did it a couple
months ago. I got they they baptized me.
I'm so
Yes. Yes, so just recently I was I was
chrismated and everything. So that's why
now I'm a Christian, but I left like I
said, I left Islam
unofficially,
I guess like a year and some change ago,
but I guess officially when I became
Orthodox Christian.
What I
But you you and God Logic were the main
people for for that conversion. A little
bit of Christian Prince. Um and I was
also watching like Shabir Ally and Zakir
Naik and honestly, I didn't find any of
their arguments to be compelling. Oh
yeah, they're they're jokes and Shabir
Ally is the biggest joke and kind of a
deceiver cuz he tries to mask it with
sounding like he's scholarly when he's
not.
He quotes sources out of context
inconsistently and doesn't apply the
same arguments to Islam, which would be
his religion.
Right. And I just found that to be very
disingenuous. And
>> cuz initially when I saw you, I was
like, oh, you know, he the way you know,
sometimes the way you sound is a little
aggressive. So
at at first I was like, you know, I'm
going to bust him and wait just wait and
see and I'm going to expose that he's
lying and and then and then I every
single time I tried, I was like, no,
he's actually right. Um God Logic, he's
also right. Sam Shamoun, he's right.
Christian Prince, he's right. Sometimes
although sometimes Christian Prince
makes some
arguments that are a little bit
far-fetched, but like
uh but for the most part he does make
good arguments also.
But
you in
you in particular
um I found to be the most convincing.
Um
you know, you and I saw your website
too, the Answering Islam. And
I just it just
it honestly it's like a weight lifted
off of my chest. Just
>> Glory to the Father. Glory to the
Father, Lord Jesus Christ, glory to the
Holy Spirit. May God all the glory keep
us humble. So, the Lord saved you,
you've been ransomed.
And the reason why I'm aggressive is
because you see the kind of dogs that
represent Islam online, right? Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. They are a great reason not to
become Muslim. But they think if they
can bully you and cuss you out, and you
say nothing, that makes them more bold
until we give them a taste of their own
medicine. That's why I have no respect
for the online community.
But thank the Lord not all Muslims are
that way, but we're dealing with these
dogs who mock, ridicule, insult,
blasphemy, think it's okay. But when we
do it, then they become the narcissistic
gaslighters.
Oh, yeah. I saw a lot of that. It's just
a lot of
um I mean we they say that there was a
lot of like, you know, love in Islam,
but honestly there's a it's more fear
and more like it's like, "Oh, don't do
this because, you know, something
fearful." And it's always just fear and
yes, fear and more and more.
>> Yeah, fear.
So, what you've been saved, brother?
You're now going to your Orthodox
church, stay faithful, take the
sacraments, grow in your faith, learn
about the faith, learn about the core
doctrines of the faith, study the
materials, the articles,
learn about these non-Orthodox things,
and that's it. You're on your way to
home. Stay faithful, remain faithful
till the end, and we'll be with the Lord
Jesus Christ forever. Is there anything
I can specifically help you with?
Well, I mean, I I to be honest, I came
just to thank you
because
because there there's been times where I
came to obviously I wanted to debate you
and then I'm glad I didn't because you
probably would have
probably would have shown that I was not
so
not so accurate. So But you saw
yourself
you couldn't refute it because it's not
because I'm a genius, it's because I
gave you facts.
That's yes, you're right. Sam, I studied
Islam through and through. Like I mean I
honestly I studied it so thoroughly and
I was just looking and searching
searching all the tough Sears searching
the the Hadith searching literally
everything I can possibly find and and I
just I couldn't I found contradictions
I it's just it's just
So yeah, it was not not
it was not the way that I wanted it to
be
um
and so it at some point it caused a big
cognitive dissonance for me
and I just got depressed for a while and
then after a while I said okay jeez I
I was like I'm not going to be atheist.
I know there's I know there's God out
there and Jesus is alive. Yes and then
Jesus is Jesus is God and I'm so
thankful I say this so proudly now and I
have people are saying now that that
know me they say there's such a
difference in me and you know because I
I seem just a lot more light-hearted and
happy and joyful
and
>> Unless you deal with Muslims everyday
they'll bring the evil out of you. So
you got to be careful. Take a break.
Uh
well
I actually you know some people are not
so happy with me after I left Islam. Oh
yeah. You'd be killed on Islamic state.
You know this better than I do. Yes yes.
Um so
yeah so it's not um
not ideal scenario but
but people know the difference. They
know the difference but
um
yeah, so I don't know. I guess uh
I'd like to take my my
my old name back before I converted.
>> your old name, brother? Sam.
Your name was Sam? Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Amen. Glory to the
the try God. Glory to the Father, the
Lord Jesus Christ, the Son of God, the
Holy Spirit. Change it. Abdul Rahman is
no more. Get rid of that demonic name.
Oh, I know. I know. I'm going to 17
years of that name or 16 I should say 16
years of that name cuz I I didn't change
it right away. Um
but yeah, I'm going to go back to my
original name and
thank God. And I just wanted to thank
you and and I didn't have nothing to
debate cuz there's now we're on the
second half.
What I want you to do as you go to the
church and you pray
ask your priests as well as the saints
who are alive to pray for me and God
Logic and all of us. We need all their
prayers. I absolutely will. I absolutely
will. I hope God strengthens you and
blesses you and give you gives you all
the uh the abilities to to reach all
these souls because we really we really
need it. Honestly, I saw so much
darkness uh towards the end of when I
was in when I dug deeper into Islam
I saw so much darkness later like later
in it and
I really sincerely hope that uh people
realize that that's not the way. It's
not the way and Jesus is the way. He's
the only way.
Thank you. Well, keep praying, right?
When you go to your church, ask your
priest pray for me by name.
God Logic and everyone else that you
know is doing good work and ask
intercession of the Queen, the Theotokos
and the saints cuz they're alive and
they pray for us and they love us. Yes,
they do. Yes, they do. Thank God and
thank God for you and I just wanted to
thank you again and I will absolutely
pray for you.
>> You made our You made our night and
if I don't see you here in Jesus' name,
I'll see you in glory with Jesus cuz we
will live forever. Absolutely.
Absolutely. And as they say
What?
You were saying? No, I was just going to
say like I I don't Well, I don't know
how to say God gives you the strength,
but they say in Arabic Allah ya'tik
al-afiya, which is is is God give you
the strength, but it's like Something
else. It's like Yes. It sounds like
Allah, but we know it's the real Allah,
not the god of the Quran. We know. Yes.
Yes, we know it's the real Allah.
>> even say as you dismiss as you dismiss,
you say in the Greek Kyrie eleison.
Kyrie eleison. Kyrie eleison. Lord have
mercy. Lord have mercy. Lord have mercy,
brother.
>> Yes. Yes, I hear that so many times at
service, so
Yes. So, thank you so much. Thank you so
much again. Love you, Sammy. Thank you
so much. Amen, Sam. Sam. Yes.
>> Abd al-Masih, slave of the Messiah. Yes,
I should say that, actually.
>> Yeah, change it to Abd al-Masih, slave
of the Messiah. I will. I can't I'm I'll
probably be trying to get in look into
that like this upcoming week. I'm going
to try to change my name legally.
And I'm here anytime you want to join a
livestream, just say it's me.
Okay. I sure will. Thank you so much.
Glory be with you, brother. Glory to
you.
Glory to Jesus. Glory to God. Glory to
you, Lord Jesus. Glory to the Holy
Spirit. And the glory we have is the
glory we share in unity with the Lord
Jesus Christ who glorifies us. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Thank you. Glory be with
you, brother. All right. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
So, this was of the Lord Jesus Christ.
So, Abd al-Rahman, if I throw out stuff
to make room, okay. This was of the Lord
Jesus Christ. You know why he showed up?
I'll tell you.
Again, I don't know definitely cuz I'm
not a prophet.
The Lord Jesus had him come to silence
my opponents,
these dogs who bark at me and insult me
and say that I'm not Christ-like and I'm
not winning Muslims to Christ.
So, guys, please
uh Christ over all, Jeremy,
and all others, clip this part. Make a
clip out of this.
Take this 10-minute conversation, clip
it.
Christ overall Jeremy, clip it.
So I can then share it with others.
The Lord brought him here for one
reason, I believe.
To then silence the dogs, the pigs who
slander me and say my approach is not
Christ-like.
That I'm not being Jesus and I don't win
anyone to Christ.
May the Lord Jesus get the glory and I
don't get any attention, but this was
the Lord of silencing you pigs.
Stop telling me what to do like the Holy
Spirit rain me and correct me and change
me. Cuz you heard what he said. He said
he fact-checked me.
And he found nothing where I lied or I
distorted the sources.
And it's not a competition. He goes, "Of
all the folks
you you are the one who had the most
impact because
you your references were spot-on.
100% accurate. No error."